welcome to another episode of not too
deep I'm your host grace and how big the
first it is a very exciting episode we
have Jack Conte here with us if you
haven't heard of him get ready to feel
like you are lazy this man does it all
he's the CEO of patreon he has a band
called Pomplamoose with his beautiful
wife he's got another band called scary
pockets that he's very very embarrassed
about the name but we'll get into that
we talk about everything from what it's
like growing up in the YouTube space
being a CEO of a company and also oddly
we both have been inspired by Snoop Dogg
directly at different points in our
lives so get ready for this very
exciting episode of not too deep with
jack conte indulge in delicious
chocolate truffles from cocoa topia
that's only 40 calories with less fat
and sugar than the other guys it's
perfect
to treat yourself after a long day you
can go to cocoa topia calm and enter
promo code grace at checkout to get 50%
off your first order make sure you type
the code in all caps go to cocoa topia
co-ceo top-8 comm and enter promo code
grace grac e in all caps at checkout for
50% off your first order indulge without
the guilt jack counties yeah
thank God I'm so excited I'm gonna ask
you I've decided we've been doing this
podcast like five or six years now and
I've decided to really polarize and make
my guests uncomfortable with an opening
question that I can work shopping with
Jeff straight into it all right the
question is what's your deal what's my
deal okay this is where the origin of
this question came about and I so I was
curious to hear your reaction to it
because as someone that wears a lot of
hats this question gets proposed to be
in so many different forms yeah and it's
always uncomfortable be like how do you
describe yourself right what's your deal
right what's your logline
that's like an aggressive part of the
question too it's almost as if like
you're doing something wrong it's like
what's your taking you exactly egging
into a very warm and wonderful
conversation what's my deal I'm uh I'm a
creator I've been a youtuber for the
last 10 years and then about six years
ago I started this company called
patreon and beautiful company thank you
thank you kindly and now I'm like trying
to figure out how to be a CEO and a
crater and it's hard and weird and I'm
learning a lot and I love it and yeah
I'm working hard and I've ever worked my
life and but then you also have this
like side
music creative hustle that I when I
started deep diving into your world I
was like is this really is this a parody
like thing like is this really him and
then I was like oh I bet this is a
wonderful like outlet balanced every
professional thing you're doing every
CEO asked thing that you're doing
totally yeah okay
I mean problem is just just for the
record that pop news came first way
before a patreon I mean we I was doing
Pomplamoose in 2000 right when you yeah
when you go back on YouTube like some of
your first videos are the music videos
and this is a band started with your
wife yeah yeah okay yeah she was my
girlfriend at the time but then we thank
God with that conversation like I'm
going like should we make music together
it was okay the true story is it was
[ __ ] heart can I say I can stalk you
can ii swear it was hard we broke up
going we're going for it yeah we started
so I am NOT very good with members of
the other sex okay quickly I'm a very
nervous kind of shy person sure and for
whatever reason when I saw Natalie
perform I was like I I was head over
heels I fell oh you watch her perform
before you guys started dating it was
that totally infatuated totally
infatuated it was like cinematic moment
and I went up to her efforts and we
started talking and immediately we you
know I I wanted to produce a record of
hers cuz I thought she was amazing
she wasn't thanks for the time in this
context like a euphemism I produce a
record of her yeah I bet you did oh the
studio
that's like not sexual especially
considering in the studio most the time
you're just sweating and bored and
sitting there with nothing to do but so
I should call my house my studio so so I
went afterwards I was like hey let's all
produce your record uh-huh so to speak
and she said yes and so we started
working on this record together and at
the same time we also started kind of
falling in love and dating and it was so
hard it was it didn't work I mean it
yeah we broke up it was cuz you're you
don't have that foundation of trust
right you know and so when you have to
give like tough feedback about like
let's do this or let's do this you know
it's it's hard to disconnect your
personal feelings from the work feeling
I guess yeah it's like too much at once
yeah yeah but that's a lot that's very
optimistic of you guys to take that on
immediately we it's aggressive I think
optimistic yes that's very nice word
yeah we did that broke up got back
together a little while later and then
didn't do music for like two years so
and we just built that foundation and
that trust and the relationship you
learned your lesson
we didn't yeah then we started making
music together and it was like seamless
and easy and the most joyful
collaboration I've ever had in my life
that's amazing yeah it was great but now
you also have what's the other band you
have Jerry pockets yeah
okay I need to hear one hi the name came
about so dorky I'm so no okay my older
brother was in a punk ska band in South
Jersey when I was in high school and
it's called shoveled up for short but
the long version is shoveled up corpses
dead rotting you is the name of his punk
ska band that when he I know and when
you told me that name with like straight
like this is not ironic this is we
believe in this I was like oh no we're
gonna have different paths pockets okay
so the idea was I so now I'm I'm in
full-time CEO mode which is like a
triple time job and so I really don't
have a lot of time
make music anymore which you know we can
get that's a whole other yeah we're
gonna talk about as much as we can don't
worry okay so so um in the meantime I
still wanted some way to be able to make
music because I'm such a joyful
wonderful experience for me and so I
have a buddy in LA who's you know
touring musician he's played with John
Legend he was John Legend's MD and he's
been on tour little olds and played bass
for Ben Folds and anyway he just knows
everybody and all these great players
and all these great musicians and and
the idea was hey let me fly down to LA
once a month you have this amazing
network of amazing musicians that are
like the best musicians in the world and
so let's like put together a band once a
month a new band every month and just
like get in the studio one day release
write and record or well rather arrange
and record four songs release them once
a month once a week for a month and then
it's nut next month fly down to it again
so we started doing that and it worked
really well people love watching it and
so also for your creative brain that's
just constantly gears in motion yeah I
get to like come down and be just
totally creative and free and
experimental and you know it's fun we we
come down you know when we arrive at the
studio we have nothing planned so it's
just it's really improvisational yeah it
feels like whatever we make true form of
collaboration it seems like like
trusting that everyone's instincts are
good totally yeah that's fun that's I
love it okay so name came out Oh
so the name goddamnit embarrassed oh
you're embarrassed by it and you're
skirting the issue I'm gonna keep your
jacket it's really the right girl Pappa
YouTube this from the last time I was
invited to YouTube rewind so okay how
about you can imagine spend six hours to
do half a second really great sounds
like a recording studio yep yep yep okay
scary pocket yeah keep back I love the
wife story but I'm really want to blaze
by that and get the scary broken scary
pockets
unfortunately the idea was we want to
have a lot of fun together we want to be
able to tour unfortune
the ideas that you wanna know
unfortunately that was in reference to
the name the idea was it was all about
the groove we wanted to just cuz
musically I get really in the weeds I
care a lot about harmony and I like get
all artsy fartsy and I want to sometimes
I'm my own worst enemy when it comes to
making things and the idea was [ __ ] it
let's just have fun let's make it all
about the group let's just make amazing
funk music let's just concentrate on the
pocket is is the word look cool play in
the pocket and the idea was here's where
it's unfortunate and just so gross and
awful the pocket is so good it's good
story the name that's a fun name things
like cool and interesting could have
10,000 different ways that it got to
that point unfortunately it's the worst
of those 10,000 ways it's true to what
you guys are feeling it's very nice of
you how long has that been formed
together we just had our two year
anniversary cool yeah two years and that
must feel like I said like with you
being this like intense CEO having this
moment happen it must feel like a
welcome reprieve to be able to go over
and just like get in your scary pocket
for a second it's the best I love it and
I love publishing stuff I love making
you know videos and I would never guess
right
but you were saying so you're it because
you're really wrapped up in a lot of
other very important things you had to
cast or is that the right word for like
getting a new keyboard play oh yeah we
hired a keyboard player who's amazing
and has an awesome voice way better than
me okay so now he's doing the tour and
said to me because I can't leave my job
for a month right right right yeah so
let's talk about your current job and it
takes up the majority of your time yeah
patreon yeah how I am a new patron at
patreon a new creator that has been
using the platform and loves it very
much and is still kind of tumbling
through and figure it all out
and being wild they kind of impressed
and excited about the community that it
helps build a lot like in the beginning
days of YouTube but it feels a little
bit more intimate and a little bit more
creative in the way that you can build
your community and you know give back to
your community and vice versa how would
you describe this platform to an alien
yeah - and does the alien speak English
let's say that alien just got rid of
their snapchat and we're looking for
something else to get on board all right
yeah so they understand that
fundamentally yeah I would I would say
the thing that I've said 10,000 times
yeah which is patreon is a membership
platform that makes it really easy for
artists and creators to get paid I mean
I'll give you all my money
question I am so curious because when I
was going through and looking everything
up about you you do a lot of talks
obviously as a CEO a company a lot of
like TED talk ease situations what do
you hate the most about those about
doing talks mm-hmm or do you love doing
them I do really like doing talks if
there's something that bugs me um oh
okay this is like a really specific
stupid thing yeah wait I love
specificity it bugs the [ __ ] out of it
okay the clickers presentation and
there's like a two second delay on the
slides oh dang and I do one of those
like the talks that I give I do you know
a thirty minute talk we'll have 750
slides I just like it's like a blog you
know I do really fast an interesting way
- yeah and so like that's just how I
communicate it's like a combination of
like words and pictures and so I use
there's like sometimes two slides a
second yeah and the clickers yeah you
can't do it with the clicker and it's
like the most infuriating it like drives
me absolutely nana's so I'm like what we
do is we have them put the laptop on
stage uh-huh but then they always have
to like wire a cable from the back
because the blow and it's so a mess it's
a mess and you would think in this day
and age I think they would have that
figured out by now so you go and
soundcheck but really it's just you
checking the clicker the whole time
never [ __ ] works amazing
amazing well I've done a couple of those
in my day but never like they're always
very nerve-wracking and though it's like
very fun but also like bizarre in a way
do you have a certain way that you prep
for those kind of situations for talks
yeah yes the audiences are obviously
very different than when you go and play
music totally yeah and yeah for me like
I have to know who the audience is I
have to know who I'm speaking to
right always I only like talking to
craters I really don't like giving talks
for it's so interesting I was watching
not to cut you off but I was watching
your videos and you open with like hello
creators yeah
you have pinpointed this type of person
that you want to talk to you and I think
a lot of creators don't even realize
that they're creators yeah it was nice
to be told that totally yeah oh wow cool
I mean the reason I do that is I guess
cuz yeah I just don't
I feel like craters are my people and I
know how to talk to craters and there's
a lot of people I don't know how to talk
to you so [ __ ] it
I'll just talk to women so anyway yeah
that's why I say like hey creators I
love that what have you ever had an
uncomfortable speaking engagement I mean
they're always uncomfortable obviously
but is has there been any particular
sort of standout moments that have been
like I can't believe that happened
yeah because one time my very first like
speaking arrangement that I'd even know
that I was doing and I was working for a
website called My Damn Channel and they
had me go do like the upfront which I
didn't understand what that was I just
knew I was being given like a piece of
paper with notes on it and then I would
come out in between people like yourself
talking at a bunch of people with money
to ask for their money I made them all
do the choo-choo noise as adults I think
I was 22 and I was like let's all ride
this train together go choo-choo and
then I made them all say choo-choo and
then I made them all realize that they
were 40 year olds it just all said choo
choo together and then I was like I
don't think that was the correct thing
to do in this moment I don't know what
my protocol is right now that's me so
that's my standup pretty good well I
don't think I can top that personally
but let me give you one that my wife has
had because that's one of my favorite
here this so she was doing like a
showcase she's a one obviously wonderful
singer-songwriter and she was doing this
showcase for some one of these film
festivals I don't even know what it was
okay oh what's the film festival in like
Colorado um whatever Sundance yeah yes I
think it was for that or something like
that okay
and so she we slam dance or something
whatever she's in one of those smallish
rooms like 50 people yeah and it's a
it's a showcase for artists and there's
all like music supervisors and the
audience so some high stakes oh yeah
yeah
as a musician this is like you what like
this is your moment yeah one of these
people it's a song in their show
it's marigolds so she's there and she
she says because hey everybody my name
is Natalie dawn like Breaking Dawn which
was the movie and then she goes which is
incidentally also the name of the porno
I started last week she she would kill
me if she knew I was telling this story
she was mortified amazing like couldn't
she just was honest things she's never
has forgotten that moment that's amazing
but then you go that's an example of why
I don't do stand-up here's me doing
music I'm much better at this here we go
welcome oh I appreciate the gussto that
it takes to go out and actually deliver
this oh yeah talk about she really went
for it
god bless those rooms are not kind no in
there they're being like right do your
song impress me please oh nice oh my god
okay we're gonna take a really quick
break when we get back I have a bunch of
other questions about patreon about
being a CEO it's gonna be sorry
listeners a lot of like me selfishly
wanting to know how to be professional
in this digital world so just buckle up
we'll be right back with more not too
deep
[Music]
to deep support for today's show comes
from bareMinerals creators of clean
beauty purity in formulation and
uncompromising performance have always
been the guiding principles of
bareMinerals because they believe that
makeup and skin care should make your
skin better not just better looking and
this has been the bareMinerals
philosophy since they began the clean
beautiful in with their best-selling
original foundation which offers creamy
lightweight buildable coverage that's
naturally luminous the clean formula is
made with only 5 good for skin
ingredients all minerals including
non-chemical SPF protection makeup so
pure you can sleep in it and it actually
improves your skin over time it's
everything your skin needs and nothing
it doesn't and for bare minerals to be
clean without compromise means good for
skin formulas with proven performance
and like every bare minerals product
it's 100% cruelty free and better yet
both the original and matte loose powder
foundations are available in 30 shades
so upgrade to clean beauty products use
the foundation finder at bare minerals
calm to find your perfect match and
first time customers will get 15% off
when you use the promo code not too deep
that's bare minerals calm promo code not
too deep for 15% off your first purchase
bare minerals the power of good let's
get some straight here people your teeth
this episode about your deep is brought
to you by the smile direct club smile
direct club straightens your teeth for
60% less than braces with invisible
aligners sent directly to you you simply
go online and book a free 3d scan at one
of their smile shops or you can order an
at-home impression kit then they'll
email a preview of your new smile and
once you get your aligners one of smile
direct club's duly licensed doctors will
check in on your progress every 90 days
so visit smile direct Club Calm for real
before and after photos of some of the
five hundred and fifty thousand plus
satisfied Greeners how cute is that not
customers grandeurs and exclusive to you
our beautiful listeners you can get $100
off your invisible aligners when you go
to smile
direct club.com slash podcasts and use
offer code grace 100 you'll also get a
$25 Amazon gift card with a free 3d scan
at one of their smile shops or a $25
rebate on an at-home impression kit
that's $100 off at smell direct Club
comm slash podcast offer code grace 100
smile direct club.com slash podcast
offer code grace 100 okay we're back
with jack conte Renaissance man
extraordinaire I do you okay let's talk
about patreon great how did this start
how did it start it started six years
ago when I well as accumulation of a lot
of things but the most immediate story
is as working on a music video mm-hmm I
spent three months on this video I
drained my savings account I max out two
credit cards it involved a 3d printed
hexapod robot and an animatronic head
that was singing lyrics to the song I
was working 16-hour days for the right
please continue and I built a replica of
a lynnium Falcon cockpit behind me to
film this music video today the course
right yeah and you know I knew I'd
upload it to YouTube I get about a
million views that's what my videos
usually getting at the time and I knew
I'd make a few hundred dollars of ad
revenue from it sure and I sort of
couldn't stomach the idea feeling like
wait a minute I'm doing my job like I'm
reaching millions of people yeah and I'm
getting paid $200 for that like I mean
what what planet are we on yeah
where you can be a crater that has even
if it's like say a basketball stadium
full of people say it's only 20,000
people that you're reaching with your
thing only 20,000 again like that's a
think about the energy and volume and
excitement of 20,000 people in a
basketball Stadium you release a thing
and reach that many people and get paid
a few hundred dollars that's totally
[ __ ] yeah and as a creator I felt like
it was totally [ __ ] and I thought God
what if I just asked my fans to kind of
become members like you know don't be
easy or whatever NPR or KQED or
something like that and that was the
idea I pitched it to my freshman year
roommate in college who happened to be a
wonderful programmer and an entrepreneur
he built it in
three months by himself oh my god and
then within two weeks of launching it
within two weeks I was making $6,000 per
that per month instead of a hundred
dollars per month yeah and that was so
motivating better yeah that might say
that's better that way what's going on
before but you know to tell you the
truth it there was another aspect of it
and I mean strangely folks like you were
a lot of inspiration and and your story
and seeing your fans follow you yeah
channels yeah it's a really powerful and
like hard to process thing as a creator
and and there is this there was this
feeling of like wait a minute fans go
where creators are mm-hmm
the fans follow creators yeah and if a
creator says hey I'm going over here now
and doing this mm-hmm fans go with that
yeah yeah and so um you know that the
thought was like gosh I know my
community's gonna like come along on
this mm-hmm and and other creators saw
that and their communities came along
too and that's the cat's the dynamic
that's basically made patreon work as a
creator says hey I'm doing this thing
come with me and people come with them
yeah it's been interesting because
mamrie and I used the platform now but
we were hesitant because if as people
that want to be comedians and exists in
the entertainment industry and let our
work speak for itself but also still
want to maintain a dialogue and a
relationship with an audience it feels a
little like self-serving to ask them to
just come and support you on this other
I mean I've always had a issue in like
trusting the the entertainment value
that you provide being enough that
someone wants to follow you somewhere
and it's been like this wonderful i
opening thing for us to realize that not
only is it audience members and
participants in a community following
the people that they've been following
for a while over to a different platform
but then like literally the game Sims
building or Sim City building their own
communities that ourselves to
self-sustaining amongst themselves that
has been like the most beautiful thing
for us to see which is we're still
processing how it all works and it's
just we're constantly like are you guys
good is everyone there like we're more
than good
having a great time you know what's so
funny is like you you're asking me about
talks that I give mm-hmm the one thing
that I basically talk about every time
that I tell creators every time is like
you are worth it like it's a weird like
you have to really like [ __ ] Tony
Robbins amp yourself let yourself know
that like the value that you provide is
special for people and like tangible and
effective in people's lives more than
you know and that's I think hard to
fully stomach as a creator to be like
how much I want to give more and more
because they're paying me with their
attention and now they're actually
paying to like be part of this journey
for lack of a better word since Chelsea
Handler has pointed out that The
Bachelor is ruined that word so it's
yeah it's a it's something that has been
really a new thing that I think is
really cool because it really resonates
as someone that started in the beginning
phases of YouTube like you did like the
idea of building this community and
understanding like the dual dialogue
that you get to have like the open
dialogue that you get to have with
versus like traditional media it's very
very cool but in like in the worlds of
like the GoFundMe is and all these other
sort of like crowdsourcing type of sites
did that come into play like when you
guys were developing this or you were
doing something different I don't think
of it in that even in that same realm
like people oh yeah yeah it's like we
don't even think of them as competitors
it's a totally different thing like you
coexist with each other you're not
competing against each other well
they're they're crowdfunding platforms
yeah and we're not that we're a
membership platform like you help we
help creators grow and run their
businesses and even the vision of like
the product and where it's going we want
to basically be like back-office tools
for creators to grow and sustain their
companies yeah so it's a very different
vision than like a crowdfunding site
yeah it's almost like you are investing
in creators to build their own bars and
it's like come hang out in my bar you'll
be regulars at my bar here are the drink
specials we have to offer here are like
the happy hour hours that we have versus
no offense the try guys are [ __ ]
killing it
try guys bar it's really great but I
like to think the mayor and I are like
the Cheesecake Factory to their dave and
buster's both great but they might
provide more entertainment than we do so
what do you do now that you like what's
the major thing you've learned because
you're a young like CEO in this world I
imagine I don't know who you're like
counterparts are this is a full
assumption without any actual knowledge
what's the major thing you've learned
from starting a business like this
sharing a company like this yeah
there's I think it's been a few things
um first is and probably the biggest
thing is like how to grow teams and how
to give away things that you're scared
to give away like as a creator I did
everything the audio engineering the
production the editing the we're control
freak we're control freaks yeah because
like every detail matters yeah and you
can't scale a company like that and so
I've had to give all that stuff away and
here's the lesson though yeah the lesson
is the people that we've given it to are
so much better than me like everything
and watching them soar and be creative
and and take these ideas and run with
them and turn them into a reality and
that's been it's been a great lesson for
me and also like a little confidence
shaking cuz I'm like oh actually maybe
I'm not the best of everything
Snoop Dogg said one thing at a YouTube
summit that stuck with me forever is
that he builds a team and he wants to be
the dumbest person on his team that's it
yeah I was like this is so profound
thank you mister Snoop Dogg yeah
and that's but that's like you know
that's a little bit of a challenge too
but it's also like a kick to your ego to
realize you're not the best at
everything you gotta have some men
usurping your power to someone that can
very easily do it so much better than
you could stay up all night trying to
figure I can do it backwards and in
heels in circles around you all night
yep and that's yeah that's uh that's
pretty special to see it I'd like it
it's a good kind of hurt it hurts yeah
we good so that's maybe one thing and
then let's see another thing
gosh the the this is yeah the the
logistics and the financials of scaling
and organization and managing profit
against expense and how to grow those
things in a healthful long-term way I've
taken those lessons and applied them now
- Papa Luis and scarier pockets Oh
interesting Ben it's been so hot like I
want I want all creators to have that
those tools yes and so we you know we
want to build a lot of that into patreon
and educational tools and like partner
manage you know part of relationships
and things like yeah but it's been
really powerful for me to to learn that
skill set that's great I also think that
all of these lessons even though they're
super specific to this giant company
that you're building
they are scalable to anyone that's
starting their own business in any
fashion that's out of the creative realm
- totally yeah totally I think that's
super important how do you do you did
you like sit-down interviews with
employees oh yeah that's what my days
are yeah like makes me sweat and gives
me anxiety just hearing like that sort
of situation
wait why like with current employees are
with like like cities like Canada yeah
like auditioning which I hate very much
and I still participate in and it brings
me lots of discomfort and you know but
also you are like just [ __ ] martyrs
for whatever it was trying to get out of
anything
what what's your go-to like interview
question yeah so my says you're a
creative company's imagine you're
interviewing camp candidates in a more
creative way or just asking different
questions and if they're gonna be a bank
teller or something right yeah you know
the gosh there's some block-and-tackle
stuff that so I've read a couple books
on that and tackle know just like the
basic foundational building blocks of
how to
do things okay um and look there's no
right way to do like do whatever you
want and I've heard of people running
successful interviews where they like
solve a problem together so I'm like
great sure for it but for me what I
found to be effective is this isn't
boring but no I think for people that
because I would love to hear this from
someone that's successful like company
creator yeah as someone that wants to
interview for companies because I feel
like no one I wish they'd taught a class
in college like here's how you interview
yeah I interviewed for the NBC page
program and highly [ __ ] it up no idea
what to talk about and how to answer
questions yeah or anything like that so
I think that there is something
interesting hearing from your
perspective like this is what I asked a
question like this yeah so I get really
um it's not really set questions I get
really curious out about a person's past
work experience I don't ask like what
would you do I don't ask them about
patreon I don't ask them about like okay
so if we were to blah blah blah how
would you solve this yeah out of that
it's always like so what were you hired
to do who hired you how did it go what
gold
did you set who set that goal did you
set it were you told that goal how do
you know it was interesting and then and
then you and literally like the kinds of
things so people will finish an
interview with me and they'll I've had
multiple people say to me like I've
never had to answer that's like specific
of a question about a job that I had
four years ago ever you might have
unintentionally Sarah pies though like
you might have unlocked some like
deep-seated ship for some people well
people love talking about like sometimes
people end up just like complaining
about a co-worker is really useful and
you can kind of really you get a sense
of what is it gonna be like to work with
this person yeah or they get like I'll
literally say like somebody will say
something like oh and that was a
terrible idea and I'll say oh you
thought that that person's idea wasn't
terrible thing they'll say yeah I'll say
did you tell them and they'll say no and
I'll be like oh okay so now I know like
this person like won't let me know if
ideas that they think are terrible come
across the brain yeah or I'll say like
why didn't you tell them you know and
then I'll literally like get into
minutiae like
but then you get a sense like when you
finish you know when you finish a 3-hour
interview like that you know like is
this person candid they ambitious like
are they creative do they are they
control freaks or do they let go too you
can learn a lot by asking those kinds of
questions that's interesting yeah now I
want you to start a podcast that's just
your interviews with potential it would
be awful okay what would you tell
fifteen year old Jack so it's gonna be
okay it's gonna be okay it's gonna be
okay
really like if this is yes it's gonna be
okay don't worry fifty Jack was so
anxious and worried and scared I think
we all were I think that none of our 15
year old selves would believe our adult
cells telling us that it's gonna be okay
No
in hindsight I am yeah if I told 50 no
grace would probably be the exact same
thing and she'd be like you don't know
what you're talkin okay are there any
creative projects that you have zero
part of but are so excited to see happen
mm-hmm because I I watched your we had L
Mills on the podcast a couple weeks ago
and I watched your video like
chronicling trying to figure out like
what makes her so special and it was
really fascinating to see it be broken
down in like such an academic way almost
and she's just I same feeling that when
I first saw her videos I got mad at them
because I thought they were so good and
I was like why how does my brain not
work like that it's so young and she's
so wise beyond her years and thoughtful
and effortlessly thoughtful even though
it's very calculated thoughtful yeah and
so I feel like you identify same with
like Casey nice that and people like
that like people that you think are
doing great things and ideas that you
think are great is there anything that's
happening kind of currently that you're
like that [ __ ] rules I'm not part of
it but that's really cool so many things
it's like more and more nowadays really
I mean you mentioned a few of them just
now I think is
really special her storytelling is
next-level yeah I think what mythical is
doing is so boundary-pushing
they're the reason I started this
podcast is because I got on their
podcast and they made me open up too
much and I didn't want anyone to have to
feel that way and now here we are
talking about your inner feelings they
continue to evolve in a way that I am
like perfect yeah great you guys are
doing it so well I don't feel like
nervous for the expansion of your
company I know it feels smart and right
yeah yeah I would say kind of funny too
is pretty impressive
okay I'm not familiar it's similar to
similar to mythical okay um in that
they're they're able to kind of grow it
but it's it still feels really true and
real and not corporate II but they're
but they're you know I think that teams
back oh I think what I think what Phil
DeFranco is doing is really cool yeah
that's awesome Issa Rae is mind blowing
she rules God she rules yeah if she ever
got on this progress I think I just sit
in silence for an hour you have I'd love
you to talk about anything you want to
you can sleep it's cool yeah yeah I mean
that there's that there's a few folks
yeah very cool do you still keep up with
like the YouTube world as much very much
so I have a hundred and twenty
subscriptions I watch all this I mean I
watch everything every time but but yes
I'm very I'm very yeah
do you watch anything outside like
what's your go-to guilty pleasure
do you watch reality TV at all it's
basically what I'm getting at it's a
long way to get to do you watch The
Bachelor I watch Parks and Rec guilty
that's a great show okay but I'm on my
third time through my wife we just love
it so what it's totally fair god it's so
good Ron Swanson and Leslie Knope
I'm in love true wonderful wonderful
humans yep okay how do you get
Pomplamoose as a name pomplamoose is a
silly sounding word yep and it is a
French word that means grapefruit right
now there's Pomplamoose yeah let's look
why is Pomplamoose right yeah if it's
misspelled yeah what how what I don't
understand this because if you had a
band name that was spelled like the
French version of pop news nobody would
be able to spell it so we just made the
spelling American II okay yeah cuz I was
like going through it's being like wait
a minute which one's spelled wrong oh no
I can't tell I've never actually written
this word out before how is this wait
I'm curious sorry I'm backtracking a
little bit but what did you open up
about with rhett and Link on your
biscuits what was the moment where you
like oh I'm really sure so I was on the
very first episode of their podcast and
they basically I went to their old old
old studios and then they shot like a
video with them and they're like we
would like to we're doing a podcast you
want to come be on it I was like okay
and this took me downstairs to a dark
room that had like one interrogation
light and we sat around a wood table
much like this but it was circular and
I've seen that table yeah and so today
it was just basically like we were just
very they remind me of my brothers and
so we just started talking about YouTube
and talking about like I was moving to
Los Angeles and talking about more of my
personal life that I at that point in my
youtube career hardly ever talked about
forgetting that like I'm on a podcast
with them like really feeling like I'm
talking to these people that I respect
and admire in the YouTube space I'm
getting to have a real like adult
intimate conversation where we're both
curious about each other's experiences
and then realizing oh this is being
recorded I'm gonna put be put out there
oh okay and I left being like who I
think I was fine yeah at that point like
everything was comedy first and like
anything about my personal life was like
tertiary at most and so it they just
created this very warm wonderful curious
environment that I really loved very
and then Hannah did it a couple weeks
later and she'd literally like called me
after the podcast and was like I have to
ask them to take some stuff out because
they got me too comfortable and I
started opening up how do they do that
they're just wonderful humans they're
just sure to the core just good they
have no ulterior motive they're
genuinely curious about people and I
walked away going I won't make anyone
feel that way until now and then I
realized like the importance of it and
they're just like yeah they're
groundbreaking also it was at the same
time that I was trying to do stuff in
traditional the same way that they just
come off like commercial kings and like
had been bridging the gap without anyone
really kind of acknowledging them for
doing that and so they were real like as
someone that was doing traditional
comedy and YouTube at a time that like
traditional comedians didn't really
respect the digital space yet I felt
like why is no one like giving them
credit where credit is due like these
guys have done everything I feel the
same way yeah and I just like so the
fact that they asked me to do this thing
was just like so unbelievable and
lackaday doing it yeah I know it's just
like they're this is so wonderful and I
really admire their trajectory and like
it was kind of just me wanting to hear
more about them off camera kind of
because it felt like they were more
themselves - yeah but yeah it was one it
was like the first time of being like
there's also maybe the first podcast I
had ever done I'm not sure so is also
that uncomfortable feeling of like so
you don't edit this in to jump cut sound
bites that only lasts for two minutes
max yes that's what the algorithm is
whatever the [ __ ] the algorithm is
speaking of trajectories and career
trajectories are you turning this around
and starting to interview me that's not
not what I was gonna do I'm actually
curious though because I only saw I saw
it from the outside and if you've talked
about this too much and it's and you
know that's fine but the transition from
Daily Grace to its grace yeah was one of
those moments at least from the outside
that was so badass and oh thank you it
was not my choice well so that that's
what I was wondering like yeah so the
basic like the
I couldn't talk about at the time
because it was a legal thing but I was
hired by My Damn Channel when I first
start making videos as an independent
contractor right and so then I was
making videos that made it look like I
was a completely independent creative
that owned all over a property but they
owned the IP for every single video I
made I did it all myself shot it
uploaded it promoted it did everything
and so when we tried to negotiate a
contract like a year when it was ending
for me to get ownership and like still
give them a cut and whatever and they
were just like strong holding no and so
my agent at the time because when I
first started meeting people in the
YouTube space I still thought YouTube
was my survival job while I auditioned
to try and do the Tina Fey trajectory
and then I met Hannah Hart and she
opened my eyes of this is actually a
field that has opportunity and that she
was you know coming from being a
Japanese translator to realizing that
now this is this new opportunity she's
gonna learn how the business works and
figure it out and I was like oh okay
yeah okay this makes sense to me and so
she was really inspirational in me
figuring out like this actually might be
where I should shift my focus I can
still audition and do all that and do
improv comedy and whatever but this
thing has so such value that I don't
even know yet what's gonna happen with
it and so my contract was ending and we
tried to negotiate didn't work out my
agent at the time tried to he literally
like sat me down and talked to me it's
like you have to think about walking
away from this because we've been trying
for months to make this contract work
and their absolute resolute like no and
so are you okay with walking away and it
was the other option though to just stay
and keep I'm sure was just stay keep
doing it and like let that they paid me
a salary so I I've never been a numbers
person on YouTube and I still have that
like conditioned into me that I don't
look at numbers I don't look at
subscriber counts because for the first
few years of me being on the platform
that didn't affect how much money I was
made I was being paid the same no matter
how many people were watching so I was
my primary concern was making content
that I thought was funny trying to make
people laugh that was it I knew I was
making the same salary regardless of
whether this video did really well or
this video that was weird that I liked
so much more didn't do really well and
didn't really matter it only bruised my
ego a little bit one of the videos I
really liked creatively didn't do as
well all of that feeling and this is
before like you know clickbait wasn't
like this thing you know that sort of
click baby culture it wasn't the thing
like I never made thumbnails I didn't
really try to take advantage of that
because it didn't affect my salary ever
and so it was a very weird thing and the
green brothers were like the true
champions of when I told them this thing
that I have to leave this company and
I'm not legally allowed to explain this
to an audience they were fired up about
it and they wrote these really well
amazingly articulated Tumblr posts that
explained my whole situation because I
got locked out of my account at the end
of the year when the contract ran up and
I had already created this new channel
that was my original channel before I
started getting paid to make videos and
it just kind of read quote branded it
and so they really let like the audience
know and then reached out to a bunch of
other content creators and everyone was
just like super incredibly supportive of
like throwing their weight to their
audience to let them know that this
isn't fair what's happening I was you
know the time on YouTube I think was
very pure and it made me actually cry
because of the sense of community that I
understood the sense of community had
been to you know vidcon's and playlist
lives but that was the real moment that
I realized like oh these fans have
created a relationship with me and with
me as a person and I with them and that
my co-creators are not in the way that
when I go to an audition you're
competing against a bunch of people to
try and get apart YouTube was you
collaborate high tides raise all ships
like that was the most beautiful moment
to me and then it's all gone downhill
from there I'm trying to audition
such a gutsy move though I mean time
there I didn't feel guts people kept
telling me that and I couldn't process
that that's what it seemed like on the
outside because there was no alternative
like that was it I had to do that but at
the same time the wonderful thing about
working with like Hannah and mamrie is
that we were working on other projects
outside of YouTube and trying to
diversify like our content creation
because we started getting opportunities
so we were just saying yes so like you
want to finance a movie yeah we have we
have a script here we go
when you want us to write a book great I
have a book here we go like we just knew
this hustle of like I my philosophy was
always like the Internet could get shut
down tomorrow and what is my world look
like if that happens so I have to have
backup plans I gotta have to have skill
sets and tools and you know pots on the
fire and situations you still feel like
that does it feel like you're oh yeah it
does yeah it does definitely and I feel
like that's one of the biggest things
the piece of like you're giving your
pieces of advice that I would give to
people is like don't put all your eggs
in one basket put a lot of eggs in a
basket you really believe in but make
sure you got a couple eggs on the back
burner that are in a couple other
baskets just in case because you never
ever know and with the way that like the
YouTube climate change is so frequently
I feel like I'm so out of the game
because I don't understand nor I I'm
also you know burnout is real and so the
idea of like the creative brain going we
don't know what to produce anymore so
let's take a break for a second is kind
of like where my mind sets a little bit
we're not cutting to a nap
oh no that's a great segue oh we go back
we have your Twitter questions for jack
conte because enough about me I already
went through all this [ __ ] on rent and
links podcast your biscuits like five
years ago
[Music]
today's episode is sponsored by open fit
it's a brand new super simple streaming
service that takes all the complexity
out of losing weight and getting fit
everyone's bodies are different and open
fit gets that which is why they
personalized your needs with custom
tailored original content not to mention
with open fit you can workout anywhere
in as little as 10 minutes a day using
your computer or your web enabled TV
tablet smartphone or Roku and it's just
super easy as someone that travels a lot
but doesn't want to feel like she's her
body stayed stagnant this allows me to
get in a quick energy boosting workout
something that I you know would not find
too boring and like it said they tailor
everything directly for you anywhere I
want to open fit has changed the way
people workout and with the code grace
you can join me on a fitness journey
personalized for you use my code grace
and start using open fit for your
journey into a healthier life and right
now during the open fit 30-day challenge
you beautiful listeners get a special
extended 30-day free trial membership
and where you can lose up to 15 pounds
in 30 days you just text grace grac e to
three zero three zero three zero that's
30 30 30 and you will get full access to
all of open fits workouts and nutrition
information for free again tex grace -
30 30 30 standard message and data rates
may apply are you craving flavor and
refreshment this summer I bet you are so
pick up one of the three flavors of Bud
Light shilada
original extra lime and the newest
member of the family mango Bud Light
shilada is perfect for drinking a brunch
on the beach or just hanging with
friends in the Sun the original gelato
brings you the crisp refreshing taste of
Bud Light with the rich signature taste
of a Clamato tomato cocktail this
distinctive blend delivers a flavor
that's truly refreshing the CH alotta
extra lime has a citrusy spin on the
classic chill out of flavor and the
chill out of mango brings a tropical
touch to summertime you mean you can
enjoy this if you're at the pool you can
pour it over ice
can garnish with a slice of lime some
celery mango you could have it chilled
you can have it straight up you can have
it any way you want you can salt the rim
of your glass add a dash of hot sauce
for even more kick I mean I love a good
Bloody Mary and I also love a good crisp
beer in the summertime so this is
actually the best of both worlds pick up
a Bud Light chill out of today and learn
more at Bud Light calm
Bud Light gelada flavor that refreshes
Jack yes where we get into these Twitter
questions I'm gonna ask you the two
questions
I ask every single guest that's on the
podcast and the first is who alive or
dead would you most want to throw cold
spaghetti at cold spaghetti yes sir
who alive or dead what I most want to
throw cold spaghetti yet
weird question welcome this is how the
podcast started it was only questions
like this okay so it's somebody I don't
like
not necessarily unless there's someone
in your life I would this would be
celebratory you know mmm throwing cool
thrown wet noodles at a person that I
love you know what I'm gonna go with I
don't know why but it's coming to mind
the lead singer of Barenaked Ladies Oh
Fred no that's not that's limp Biskit is
Fred Durst fenders and the other guy
it's been that guy yeah one week she
looked at me
yeah chickadee China the Chinese chick I
want to do it I want to do it while he's
doing that wrap throw at his face sign
up for the other question ask every
single guest is it tell us your worst
pants [ __ ] story or close call but
you can only use three words or small
phrases to mine for example is college
jogging front lawn yeah specific I
probably have updated versions but this
is just my go-to car
yes petal disgusting okay I like your
voice quaked when you first started it's
never a good time I don't know that
anyone's recounted their wears pants
[ __ ] story in a loving way
like a favorite nostalgic memory don't
okay that let's get into these Twitter
questions lots of questions for you um
someone to know what's your favorite
thing made of wood my favorite thing
made of wood mm-hmm I'm gonna go with
our new kitchen table
oh my buddy made for us very cool and
it's a giant hunk of wood that he cut
you know he cut a thing out of and
planed it and made it all listen you
don't it every day no that's a
functional and fashioned at the same
time I love it it's the best that's very
sweet and someone to know what's the
worst way you or someone you know has
started a conversation I mean you told
us about your wife trying to start a
conversation dance okay the worst way
someone's ever started a conversation
with me is what's your deal I'm
workshopping it yeah if it continues
so let's know what's harder founding a
tech company or starting a band with
your wife oh you you would might think
that starting a band with your wife is
more emotional uh-huh but actually the
emotional ups and downs of starting a
tech company are otherworldly really yes
Wow I'm like every day the best thing
happens followed by like the worst thing
like every day you can't prepare for
anything yeah and it's it's it's very
emotional Ike there have been I mean if
we're going for it yeah go for it there
have been moments where I've like you
know gone to the bathroom and cried yeah
I mean this is really like a baby yeah
it's it gets hard sometimes it's also
you know like there's a lot of people's
jaw like people that are involved in
this business with you so it's like
you're not being self-serving or
literally
trying to serve other self yeah yeah
yeah it's emotion they're both emotional
do you do like company retreats mm-hmm
we do company outings so we'll go to
Angel Island for a day or something and
hey yeah we do that it's very cool play
sports eat food sweet I'd be humans
around each other just only exists male
threads uh some wanted to know any
studies relating to creators that
display their income verse those that
don't well
oh yeah I know what they're talking
about okay explain this to me this so we
we allow as a crater you can either say
how much money you're making per month
or not on your page that's the
interesting thing yeah that I've noticed
but um they're asking for studies yeah I
think what they're asking is like hey
does it help you or hurt you or is it
what is it
should you do one or the other and we've
run a b tests on that and we show that
it has no effect on craters so
interesting show your dollar amount or
not it doesn't get you more patrons or
less patrons it's it doesn't matter I
think that's really good to know because
then it comes down to personal
preference yeah what cuz that's where
memory and I were first you know trying
to figure it out it was a lot of looking
at other peoples pages and getting like
mixed signals on like they're doing this
but they're doing something totally
different and then realizing oh you just
have to decide for yourself what works
for you and like create your rules of
your community basically and there are
some people that think you know that's
say like gosh for me and my community
transparency is everything I tell them
everything I give them quarterly
financial reports and yeah and then
there's some people were like hey I'm a
private business I don't have telly when
you walk into a dentist's office it
doesn't say the dentist's salary over
the door right there like that's always
been because one of the main questions
and speaking of like question the worst
questions to get was when you know I
first start doing interviews is like
someone that was of note on YouTube or
whatever yeah it was like so you guys a
millionaire it's like how much money do
you make and remember someone mean like
it might have been Harley Morenstein
because he was so outspoken about this
and I love his completely bold
aggressive opinions about things that he
was like you wouldn't ask a doctor
that's about to like cut you up like how
much you make a year like there's no
world in which that's like a socially
acceptable question for this person I
know and so it's always been very
be interesting to me how curious people
that aren't involved in the digital
space are specifically about about the
financial gains I think there's like
this this kind of expectation that if
you're an artist you have to be public
about your financials which is just like
no right and then when this like
mythology was created that like all
youtubers are millionaires and they're
all making like unreasonable amounts of
money for absolutely no actual quote
talent or work then everyone jumped on
board that because it's easy to hate on
that situation that you try to
understand it and learn about what the
actual true value is right in the
digital space
sorry that's I'm workshopping my TED
talk right now so on to know what's the
weirdest experience you've had with a
celebrity or an artist oh I've got a
good one yes can't wait can I say this
one we can't bleep out names you can
make up fake names you can modern none
of us know the truth so you can be as
fictitious as you want okay so I went to
like a pitch once with like a button of
a bunch of people and it was a pitch for
Snoop Dogg and so sorry like a
television show or no where no like
we're talking about our companies
there's a bunch of founders there and
we're talking about her companies and
soup dogs there with his team uh-huh
so I'm at a table I'm sitting across
from Snoop Dogg and I was talking about
patreon and like how it helps people
make money and how craters are like
being undervalued by them you know the
global ad ecosystem and you know I was
really getting into of super sided I
told my story about this one webcomic
that we have named Zach Weiner Smith who
does this amazing comic called Saturday
morning breakfast cereal okay and so I
started telling about Saturday morning
breakfast you know you know how like
amazing is now he's making all this
money and like he can hire a team in an
assistant he can spend more time drawing
comics and I get through the whole thing
and he and Snoop Dogg is he's wearing a
[ __ ] beach at loud you can do
anything you want he's leaning back with
his arms crossed and he just goes but I
finished he goes Wiener Smith
[Music]
so good also I'm not I mean I'm a kind
of a gambling woman but I never would
have guessed that Snoop Dogg would be
brought up so much in this podcast with
you you had a Snoop Dogg story okay so I
want to know who or what is your YouTube
guilty pleasure guilty pleasure pleasure
my my YouTube pleasure okay I've been
watching potato jet a lot excuse me
I know like camera I'm a camera nerd
like yeah Erin cinematography stuff so
he's one of them another one that I
subscribed to recently I do you know
Louis Cole know the weirdest okay most
bizarre music and crazy videos where he
gets a hundred his friends to all put on
masks and march down a railroad like
track playing horns sure mixed and he's
wearing like a like a naked body suit
and smashing mailboxes it is so weird
but the songs are so deep and beautiful
and wonderful yeah it's like music Louis
Cole Louis MA
he's definitely one of them I thought do
you get into any of the ASMR or Oh
things like that so I love that it
exists yeah but I don't get it
okay so we're on the same boat yeah yeah
I don't get the tinglies me there I
understand how people could get that it
bothers me yeah I don't like it
it feels like it's offensive it's
threatening me in some way are there any
things that you like hate watch or hate
follow oh I'm so careful about that yeah
I I like it because everything's very
public and I was like a you know the
person behind a giant company matter
that you have to be much more like
strategic in the way that you operate
online I think that that's not even it
for me because like I think my watch
history is private I hope
no I think the reason I'm careful with
hate watching is because we all have so
many few minutes in our days yeah and
like why just give yourself those
feelings that's true I think I guess I
wouldn't call it hate watching I just
get so sometimes very aggressively
curious about someone that operates so
differently than I do in the world and
so I think that's the more positive spin
on hate watching that I'm just
fascinated by like the way people but
also I guess not hate watching it's just
like full curiosity of like I don't like
share for instance wouldn't be a hate
follow for me but she is she tweets in
such hieroglyphics that are so
unfathomable like that I can't fully
process that I'm it's like my it's its
own television show to me to watch this
happen yeah because it's like an alien
how is that happen my brain is so
different than your brain yeah so
unbelievably talented in a certain
industry that like now it's like taking
me social media but I'm like I love this
yes please okay so I want to know what
social media site would you get rid of
no consequences obviously but it just
disappears from the internet Facebook
Facebook really yeah I don't use fit I
have used Facebook hey maybe yeah
forever I mean the baby wasn't don't use
Instagram I don't really use Instagram
yeah no that's not true okay I use
insert I follow on Instagram but I don't
post oh geez creep on Instagram well
hang on a sec so I think I use Instagram
in a weird way I don't follow friends on
Instagram okay I only follow artists
okay and so I use I use Instagram I
think in a weird way every time I open
up my Instagram I feel inspired oh
that's nice and when I find something
great I get that out I double-click it
and I heart it but only when it's like
oh my god it's amazing I don't want to
forget that yeah yeah so then I go
through my hearts and it's just all like
like
I want to come up with an idea for a
music video I just go to my heart's
playlist and it's the it's mind-blowing
so you're basically creating like a
Pinterest page for yourself on instance
yes that's all that maybe I should use
Pinterest but I use Instagram oh yeah
we've had other people say that I'm like
that's a better way of doing it than
going down wormholes of just like people
that don't inspire me that I'm just like
what is this you know is this yeah so
you get rid of Facebook okay I just
don't think it's fair I think a lot of
people have that you yeah okay oh whoa
if music were a visual art form what
media and color palette do you prefer
using oh that's a heavy one that is it
cool yeah if it were a visual art form
okay it'd definitely be it'd definitely
be video okay and it would be color
palette it would be oh I'm gonna be
super artisty right now go for it would
be like it would be lots of dark clothes
colors but kind of like sandy and
textured and like Browns and dark greens
and very earthy colors that's what it
would be cool yeah sounds like you just
described a screensaver okay here's our
last question before we are gonna wrap
up in a second what does he attribute to
the fact that he and Natalie have been
making music together for so long
without losing any of their mojo it's a
not sexy answer but it's the damn truth
good communication really yes okay like
and top like tough conversations like
I'll give you a communication
communication yeah I showed up late to
date night once okay and instead of like
being instead of being pouty about it
and maybe not saying what was on her
mind
she literally just turned to me and
she's like hey when you show up 25
minutes late for a date night it makes
me feel undervalued huh and I was like
wow I do not want my wife to feel
undervalued yeah I'm not gonna show up
late to date night anymore Wow and it's
literally it's moments like that and we
do it to each other like I'll do that
with her too and just like that kind of
real-time feedback and just honesty with
each other even if it's kind of
uncomfortable yeah I think it's really
helped us feel like closer and know how
to like be respectful to each other and
be excited about being around each other
and then at that point I imagine that
you build up this like rapport with each
other where you know when the other
person's not doing that like you guys
have that ability to be that honest in
your communication that when one
person's being a little passive you're
like ah something's up yes tell me
exactly what's going on yeah there's
like no secrets oh that's great this is
you don't have to guess what's on the
other person's mind
that's good communication um okay what's
next for you what's coming up do you get
a day off do you have a K ssin you know
what I sleep I don't really get a lot of
time off but I mean I like work I'm a
workaholic sure but but what's next for
me I think okay so we have a wonderful
team at patreon we're 170 people now and
and I think what's next for me is more
stuff like I'm doing this week hanging
with creators who I'm and making sure I
stay close to craters as the company
grows and like I want to be I want to be
having conversations with folks and
learning a lot and so spent like I've
been an operational CEO for the last six
years yeah and I think the next chapter
of my CEO d'amore you know my my you
know is gonna be you know more hanging
with creators talking with creators who
are not yet on patreon well learning
about their problems what they need all
that kind of stuff I really like doing
that so I think yeah the more that we've
had creators on the podcast the more
that I've had like conversations with
friends everything's changing right now
and everything seems like it's in this
weird flux that were all having
conversations that are like what are we
doing and we're all in this like kind of
crisis mode that might ultimately be
very good but we're all kind of like
floundering a little bit just being like
what are you doing you're doing patriot
what's that okay tell me about that yeah
well that's awesome okay before you
leave I'm gonna give you every person
that makes time for me on our podcast
it's a personalized fortune cookie
that's pointing at me so I know that's
funny at you and you don't have to eat
it obviously you can I'm gonna eat it go
you know I didn't encourage it but go
for us
and do I have to read the fortune we
that that's the part I encourage okay
all right well so I'm not gonna eat it
then right now Moli did I get like
triple fortune status maybe looks like I
got several fortunes double fortunes
oranges one very long one
okay asking for a friend of a friend but
could let's say a fortune cookie have
potential with a patreon page just
asking again not for this fortune cookie
but for my friend let it linger we'll
see what happens with that patreon page
thank you fortune cookie you have a very
bright future I will sign up to any tier
that fortune cookie sets up on patreon
and now fortune cookie I will kill you
Jack where can people find you
personally online yep
people can find me maybe I'm I stop
tweeting I don't really Instagram
anymore disappointed about their social
media yeah this is very active our Papa
Lucy YouTube channel released a video
weak and scary pockets YouTube channel
we release a video a week so search pop
elusive scary pockets boom
also I highly encourage anyone that's
interested to check out patreon mamrie
and I are having a really [ __ ] great
time over there and it's just a
wonderful group of people that we've
been introduced to so it's awesome
support your creators over there in a
way that you maybe never knew you could
before yeah Thank You Jay thank you Greg
appreciate you for making time we'll see
you guys next time another episode of
not 2deep 2deep 2deep 2deep as the
creators have clean Beauty bareMinerals
is driven by a philosophy that makeup
and skincare should make your skin
better not just better-looking and
that's why their best-selling original
foundation is made with only five
ingredients that are all minerals for
bare minerals to be clean without
compromise means good for skin formulas
with proven performance so upgrade to
clean beauty products use the foundation
finder at bare minerals dot-com to find
your perfect match
and first time customers will get 15%
off when you use the promo code not too
deep
minerals the power of good not too deep
as a production of grace helbig
incorporated producer and edited by
melissa demons writing by diane kang a
production assistance by Katrina Henning
post-production sound by Chris Henry and
an extra special thanks to Flula for the
theme music